[Music]
hey everyone thanks for clicking the
video I'm your host definition and when
I woke up this morning I was outraged
outraged to tell you but not for the
reasons that you might think now I know
you guys hopefully come to this channel
for informative videos that go beyond
the headlines
so I thought I'd break down this news
story that James Bond has been replaced
by a black female and discussed kind of
the whole drama and why in my opinion
that this entire thing going on is just
so ridiculous
okay so first let's dive into the story
and how it's being reported by
tomorrow's fish and chips your paper the
Sun they are going with the headline 7up
bomb 25 will see actress lashana Lynch
take over from Daniel Craig to become
first female double-oh-seven
which naturally yeah it's gonna trigger
the internet it's been purposely written
this way to drive clicks and get people
angry because that's the kind of tabloid
that the Sun is so people are getting
really furious about this but the way
that it's written it comes across like
Daniel Craig is just gonna be tossed to
the side taken into the woods and killed
and then replace with the complete
opposite of himself which is a black
woman however when you actually go
beyond the headline you'll see that bond
is still well bond he's still a
super-secret spy agent that will shoot
the men pull the birds and drink the
vodka lads lads lads what actually
happens in the movie and full spoilers
ahead if you don't want to know anything
about the film is that James Bond has
gone into retirement after the events of
Spectre which saw him save the world
once more and spare Blofeld's life he's
called out of this when the world is
once more held to ransom by the powers
of evil and then there's a pivotal scene
at the start of the film where M played
by Ralph Fiennes says come in
double-oh-seven and in walks lashonna
she has in fact taken over his car
name and is now technically
double-oh-seven
they have not replaced James Bond with a
black woman they're not calling her Jane
blonde she's not bonds not getting a sex
change there's no need for the outrage
yet now this of course will be contested
throughout the film with bond no doubt
getting back his double-o status and
number by the film's end because because
let's face it
Hollywood only really wants to tackle
social justice issues to appear like the
tackling social justice issues because
they know it makes money and being woke
and inclusive is a great marketing
tactic what's so baffling about this
though is that it's not really a big
story that deserves all of the outrage
that is currently going on on the
internet now I'm a massive James Bond
fan I owned all the videotapes I owned
all the DVDs and I even bought all the
blu-rays I've spent too much money on
this guy so I've got the right to be as
annoyed as anyone and genuinely I can't
really see a problem with this scene
naturally though and no one actually
reads the story itself before opening
their mouth and twitter has been blasted
with some of the most idiotic tweets
ever such as how does putting a female
black lady as James Bond make any sense
whatsoever bond has always been a white
male chauvinist good-looking man that
has used his charms to sleep with lady
spies or to get duped by their charms
way to ruin a character you created
hashtag to be seen I love that one buns
always been a chauvinist
he's bloody few many not gonna be able
to have sex with the women now next is
so there's going to be a female
double-oh-seven
James Bond was written as a male
character not a female and not a
transgender the world is gonna pot let
me off please yeah a duck I don't think
you read this story there did you I
don't know where you got that
transgender bit from but it's clearly
some underlying issues there next is
this has got to be a troll I know you
have to be trolling to be this stupid
James Bond is iconic if they want to
know the female double O agent they
should write one and the movie could
complement the double-oh-seven movies a
Hatt's gender swapping characters so
much just shows the lack of creativity I
could go on for days and days about
because the Internet it's in uproar but
again these people clearly haven't read
the actual article and I think that the
marketing in movies in general plays
into the fact that they can write
outlandish headlines and people won't
bother checking and will just spout off
anything I mean to me it's really
getting ridiculous the way that movies
are marketed these days well they never
actually talked about the movies
themselves but rather the social issues
behind them I think the biggest example
that I can think of it's Captain Marvel
which made this big song and dance about
taking white men down in Hollywood and
absolutely none of that was in the film
whatsoever it was pretty much a popcorn
movie that didn't really do anything
over the line and it actually cut a very
risky scene in case people were offended
by it so yeah what a trends are the new
Bond movie is clearly doing that too and
I can guarantee that this new character
will clearly play second string to bond
before probably being tossed to the side
to show that bond is and always will be
double-oh-seven
naturally though newspapers and
journalism in general is dying so they
have to write these sensational media
pieces that gain attention because they
can no longer get it from telling the
truth the Sun headline is extremely
misleading and in truth the film shows
that the world has moved on from bond
and it's doing its own thing which is
always actually a good pop point in Bond
films that work really well in Skyfall
and the like bond is still relevant but
this makes me question whether the
fanbase is there when they have to drum
this stuff up to get people talking
about the movie The Little Mermaid was
the perfect example last week where they
drummed up lots of controversy around
the colour of Holly Bailey skin but it's
probably not gonna be mentioned at all
in the movie and it's just a case of
marketing through controversy when the
best way to promote your film is to
actually promote the film itself it just
seems like since the last Jedi things
like social issues gender and race are
all things that people focus on and talk
about when in actuality the film's
themselves don't really tackle them I
really help bond doesn't fall victim to
this false marketing technique as it's
such a moot point and it really isn't
needed this story is a prime example of
there
and I'm actually quite eager to see how
this pop poem plays out in the movie I
personally think it'll really work and
it'll kind of humble bond which is
always great to see in the films
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the issue and if you agree with the
way that movies are being marketed right
now if you're outraged over the entire
thing or just want to drop your thoughts
on it then make sure you leave them in
the comments below as I love to read
them if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and if you
want to see more formal movie coverage
that make sure you check out my recent
breakdown of Spider Man far from home
which would be linked at the end we go
over the entire movie and talk about
where the film's could go down the line
so it's definitely worth checking out
after this well so just want to let you
know that we're giving away a free copy
of Avengers endgame on blu-ray to one
lucky winner and all you have to do is
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the bond story in the
comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
August the 10th and the blu-ray will be
shipped up from then to ever get
surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
you